at least 12 people were killed overnight
in a plane crash in the Central Asian
country of Kazakhstan the aircraft
slammed into a two-story building
shortly after takeoff 93 passengers and
five crew members were on board dozens
of them were hurt the flight was
traveling from Almaty Kazakhstan largest
city to the country's capital Roxana
Saberi is following the story Roxana
what more can you tell us good morning
the plane ran into trouble shortly after
taking off from southeastern Kazakhstan
the survivor told local media the jet
that started falling and people were
screaming and crying images show the
front of the Beck airplane smashed into
a building in a residential area just
outside the airport with the rear of the
plane laying in a field nearby and video
posted online shows rescuers digging
through rubble searching for survivors
and a small child being carried away
from the scene the country's deputy
prime minister said the runway was in
ideal condition authorities are
investigating whether the crash was
caused by pilot error or technical
problems the state news agency says both
flight data recorders have been found in
good shape which should assist with a
quick analysis of the cause of the crash
in the meantime authorities have
suspended all flights in the budget
airline and the Dutch made Fokker 100
production of the aircraft ended more
than two decades ago but around 140 of
them are still active mainly in
Australia and Iran Vlad I'll take it
Roxana thank you Roxana Saberi force in
London
you